now NHS nurses have announced two strike
dates for next month affecting
non-emergency services in England Wales
and Northern Ireland the announcement
follows a ballot of 300 000 members of
the Royal College of Nursing who voted
for strikes for the first time in their
106 year history now their plan to go
ahead on Thursday the 15th and again
Tuesday the 20th of December the Royal
College of Nursing says that intensive
care and a e services will not be
affected but there will be disruption
for routine care and planned surgery the
strikes will happen across England Wales
and Northern Ireland but not at this
stage in Scotland where negotiations are
ongoing the Royal College of Nursing
wants an overall pay rise of more than
19 which the government says it simply
cannot afford well in the last hour the
Prime Minister has responded to the news
look I have enormous respect and
gratitude toward us as everyone does for
the incredible job they do and like I
know things are difficult right now for
everyone because of what's happening
with inflation and that's why our plans
that we outlined last week will get a
corruptive inflation and bring it down
that's really important and in the
meantime what what the unions are asking
for I think is a 19 pay rise and I think
most people watching will will recognize
that that's obviously unaffordable and
that's why I'm pleased that the health
secretary is sitting down talking to the
union and hopefully we can find a way
through this